[Musique]
il y a 75 ans le NRX voit le jour ce
réacteur nucléaire canadien mis en
service au laboratoire de chokriver en
Ontario sera le plus puissant de son
époque
son histoire commence lors de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale la course à l'arme
nucléaire bat son plein
[Musique]
des alliés ou des nazis développera la
formule en premier
canadien européen et américains
s'unissent un laboratoire secret est
installé à l'Université de Montréal
l'emplacement du laboratoire est bien
choisi de l'autre côté de l'océan loin
des regards indiscrets ce qui
n'empêchera pas un espion qui pénétrer
le chercheur
livre les secrets des recherches
canadiennes ou soviétiques
[Musique]
au laboratoire on étudie le comportement
des neutrons constituant avec les
protons des noyaux des atomes
on cherche les manières de produire et
d'extraire du plutonium
utile pour les réacteurs nucléaires et
on réalise la conception du réacteur de
recherche NRX
la majorité des chercheurs
ignorent que leurs travaux serviront à
concocter l'arme la plus puissante de
l'histoire ou 1945 deux bombes sont
largués sur les villes d'Hiroshima et
Nagasaki
c'est le début de la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
langue de choc se rend jusqu'aux
chercheurs du Laboratoire de Montréal
ils comprennent alors l'ampleur de leurs
recherches
[Musique]
un mois après les bombardements
atomiques sur le Japon un premier
réacteur nucléaire fonctionnel hors des
États-Unis et mis sur pied le zip
construit au laboratoire nucléaire de
Chuck River en Ontario grâce aux
recherches effectuées en amont à
Montréal il produit uniquement un watt
facile à manipuler il est peu radioactif
et de petites tailles
il sert de projets pilotes pour le
réacteur expérimental NRX qui avec ses
20 mégawatts et
il fonctionne à l’uranium naturel baigné
dans l'eau lourde provoquant une
réaction en chaîne continue
dans les années 50 il est mis à jour NRX
double en énergie il est alors couronné
du haut de ses 40 mégawatts le réacteur
le plus puissant au monde il restera
pendant des années
sa mission testée différents matériaux
et vérifier les applications de la
médecine nucléaire
il permet alors au Canada de devenir un
pionnier en médecine nucléaire grâce aux
radios
[Musique]
mais en 1952 arrive le premier grave
accident nucléaire au monde
le NRX surchauffe on appelle ce
phénomène la fusion du cœur d'un
réacteur nucléaire les effets sont
redoutables car excessivement radioactif
il faut réagir vite
l'incident persiste pendant 62 longues
secondes bien assez pour provoquer des
dégâts les accidents nucléaires sont
notés sur une échelle de 1 à 7 si
l'accident des Tchernobyl était de
niveau 7 celui de Shark River cette
année-là a atteint le niveau 5
la décontamination du NRX sèche-la sur
14 mois avant que le réacteur ne
reprenne ses activités puis il reste
actif jusqu'en 1993
malgré les graves accidents connus dans
le passé et le fait que les réacteurs
nucléaires génèrent d'importantes
quantités de déchets nucléaires dont il
est difficile de se débarquer l'énergie
atomique est reconnue pour des maîtres
aucun gaz à effet de serre ce qui fait
dire à plusieurs que la filière
nucléaire pourrait être une solution
pour l'atteinte de la carbone neutralité
comme quoi une chose tantôt destructrice
peut aussi être réparatrice
[Musique]